[Music]
all right this'll work
okay we're ready for the cobra
[Music]
he's running away from me
there we go that's just the first one
i'm all worn out okay
for the past 15 years i've made a
thousand trips to photograph
over 10 000 species and subspecies for
the photo arc
that was really really good it's a
snapshot of life on earth
before these species disappear not just
to preserve them in a frame but to get
us to care about species while there's
still time to save them
a lot of them are from the forests that
have been hammered it's a
tragedy of epic proportions we won't
save what we don't love
and we won't fall in love if we don't
connect you want to see
who's that
[Music]
i can't photograph this animal anywhere
else
they are in the 25 most endangered
permits in the world
soda work really exists for animals like
this they're so small
they don't really exist in zoos but they
help make the world go around
[Music]
in the photo arc every creature is the
same size
that's the point big or small they each
have a role and a place on this planet
it's the toughest job i've ever had but
the one that matters most